foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] Em
[Music]
I'm feeling much better
[Music]
still have a little strain on my boys
it's a little congested
this is what we have to deal with on a
day like today because we will lack with
we will not stop we will not go quietly
into the night I'm just kidding I mean
we got three days this week because it's
a holiday week it's Thanksgiving week
got a lot to talk about today though did
you know that Merrick Garland has
appointed a special counsel did you know
that did you hear this oh my God
this game is brutal
because today
he's already making arguments in court
already been fully briefed
already making arguments everyone's like
oh it's gonna slow it down
now don't appoint a special counsel
meanwhile Matt gets Marjorie Taylor
green Jim Jordan Donald Trump Steve
Bannon they're all terrified of this
special counsel
if you're wondering if the special
counsel
of Jack Smith
was a good idea or not what you need to
do is just go look at what the [ __ ]
mind the the America First manga
fascists are saying
they're terrified them they're like
we're gonna defund him not how it works
at all and by the way but
by the way to think that Republicans
that have the House of Representatives
by
two or three votes are gonna get
anything [ __ ] done anything you're
out of your [ __ ] mind
you're out of your mind these people are
going to be are positioning themselves
for their own power they always are we
can count on Republicans doing that
positioning themselves for their own
power
and let me tell you something this idea
that trumpism is popular and that every
single District that these Republicans
are elected in are secure is a bunch of
nonsense
it's a bunch of nonsense why do you
think Kevin McCarthy can't come up with
218.
he can't come up with 218
because the extremists know that he's
going to help the [ __ ] moderates
to be able to vote
they have to sell something
but they won't have anything to sell and
that's the best part Republicans [ __ ]
suck at government they [ __ ] suck at
it
not only that they want to overturn it
in Arizona I want to talk about this
with Texas Paul today in Arizona and
they're trying to get counties to not
certify an election I've heard of this
before
so there was this um event
back in 2021 it was in January I believe
it was on the sixth
where they were trying to get a vice
president I believe
his name was uh Mike Pence to not
certify a vote
and if he if he did certify the vote
they were going to hang him
you remember that
I don't know if you remember or not it's
a long time ago
but here the Maga America First Nazis
are trying to threaten that Counties in
Arizona are not going to certify
because Carrie Lake lost Blake Masters
lost
their Secretary of State Nazi lost
and of course Steve Bannon and Mike
Flynn are leaning all the way into this
because if they don't win they just deny
and they stall because they're trying to
trigger a new election which is really
stupid [ __ ]
so I guess we'll see what goes out of
that but it appears it appears that
they're practicing again
is what it appears I told you two or
three weeks before the election that it
was very clear
that Maga wanted to win Arizona like
that was the one they wanted they wanted
that one more than anything
and you're seeing why
they needed a place
where election denialism could live and
flourish that's what they were looking
for in 2020 in Georgia
that's why he was calling down there
like hey find me enough votes to win
they just need one spot
to cause chaos
that's it that's all they want because
they want [ __ ] chaos
and they want you to believe that the
elections are [ __ ] chaos they're not
chaos
they're not they were counted she
[ __ ] lost he [ __ ] lost and the
only reason why their butt hurt is
because in one County
they won by 40 percent
and the other counties got crushed
it doesn't matter what percentage you
lose by it matters how many votes
you [ __ ] boneheads
there is not an electoral college in
Arizona
for the governor
for the senate seat for the Secretary of
State it doesn't exist that little
technicality that your [ __ ] orange
Mussolini Jesus won on in 2016 doesn't
exist anywhere else
in our [ __ ] electoral system that's
the only spot
is that one
office
so what them [ __ ] show their cards
that these Republicans are going to
bully and probably commit felonies
more than likely commit felonies
because it's [ __ ] sedition folks this
is sedition
and it's textbooks Edition
that they won't accept an election
result that's free and fair and that
they won't certify because they don't
get to take over government
that's sedition
so let them [ __ ] commit felonies [ __ ]
them
it's not going to stop Katie Hobbs
Fontes and and Mark Kelly being being
sworn in
so let him [ __ ] them let them let them
show their cards let them say the quiet
part out loud we just need to point it
out we as a people need to make sure
that everyone else in the country knows
what these [ __ ] are doing
because a lot of people are just going
to bury their heads in the sand and not
watch
not pay attention
speaking of paying attention to news
Donald Trump's name is coming up in
court today all over the country all
over the country
and I don't know if
if you're paying attention oh he's not
being held accountable and we talked
about this yesterday
me and Gabe Sanchez
I said
isn't it funny how all these score cases
every [ __ ] one of them even the even
the one with Stuart Rhodes and The Oath
Keepers
there's one just one [ __ ] thing
tying all these all these [ __ ]
criminal cases
all these criminal investigations
together just one [ __ ] thing
it ain't documents
it ain't Rudy Giuliani
it ain't Steve Bannon
it's Trump trump is is at the heart of
every [ __ ] one of these things
and now he has
one of the most [ __ ]
I don't know this guy looks like Judge
Roy Bean to me this Jack Smith I don't
know if you guys know the The Legend of
Judge Roy Bean
holy [ __ ] that's what this guy looks
like the embodiment
I wouldn't want him Prosecuting me [ __ ]
that [ __ ] guy who's committed [ __ ]
War who is prosecuted war crimes and war
criminals that's the guy you [ __ ] that
[ __ ] I don't care if it's a [ __ ]
speed ticket I wouldn't want that
[ __ ] up my ass hell to the no
and if anyone's wondering if Jack Smith
is
smarter than Trump and his entire
[ __ ] team of lawyers
well we're about to [ __ ] find out
and this idea that the special counsel
is a Bad Thing boy you people who who
are out there saying oh it's just a
stall tactic it's Garland punting
if you listen to Ted Cruz this morning
if you listen to Marjorie Taylor green
Matt gatz
Steve Bannon Mike Flynn all of them
they're [ __ ] terrified
terrified of this [ __ ]
Jim Jordan Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan
Ted Cruz scared that this investigation
is going to carry on and on and on and
Jack Smith is just going to keep turning
over [ __ ] treasonous rocks
which that's kind of the point of the
special counsel
[ __ ] got all the time in the
world
and he doesn't have to bring one
conspiracy indictment if he finds
another [ __ ] conspiracy or another
[ __ ] crime committed in his
investigation he can bring that [ __ ]
these people are [ __ ]
and everyone's like oh Mueller the
Mueller investigation yeah well there
there isn't a bill Barr there's not a
bill Barr stand in that motherfucker's
way and
Donald Trump is a private [ __ ]
citizen he is not the sitting president
of the United States that's a huge
difference
that's a huge difference and it's gonna
show folks
now that you even have the Manhattan D.A
considering opening up new [ __ ] cases
which I think that one's kind of
ridiculous
and I think that's a dead end road to
beat the Stormy Daniels thing again I
mean Michael Cohen already went to
prison for it they got a conviction I
seriously doubt anything comes
from Alan weisselberg
trying to talk about
hush money checks that Trump wrote to
porn stars
doubt it I don't think that's the case
it's going to be made and I don't think
Jack Smith is going to give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] about that Stormy Daniels chick
doubt it
he cares about that [ __ ] tax fraud
though I bet
he's gonna give a lot of shits
about this true social stuff
where all this money's going all the
money he stole for for all the legal
expenses
all the money he's been grifting off his
supporters to try to get Republicans to
win elections and get didn't give a
[ __ ] nickel
come on now
come on now
you're worried that the special counsel
is a bad thing
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
I can't wait
I can't wait
till next summer because I believe
that's when shit's really gonna start
happening here I mean I think there's
going to be several indictments before
we get there hell we may even get a
Christmas gift
jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the
way
jingle those handcuffs and those leg
irons
we may get a Christmas gift I doubt it I
really think it's probably in the first
quarter next year when these indictments
start to fall you're going to see
Eastman Clark Trump
Bannon Giuliani
the stuff's gonna start to happen
we're even gonna have the proud boys
trial coming
which is where the overt violence was
seen The Oath Keepers they were trying
to sidestep that they weren't there for
violence they were there in case
violence happened I doubt that's going
to be the case in the proud boys trial
and one key figure is going to be Donald
Trump's best friend Roger Stone
and I can't I can't wait I can't wait
for Jack Smith to crawl all the way up
inside Ryder Stone's ass and live there
oh up in that [ __ ]
Roger Stone doesn't stand a chance
against a Jack Smith
him jaw jacking grinding his teeth and
depositions pleading the fifth you [ __ ]
you goddamn band of [ __ ] speaking of
that
did you know alpha male was trending
this morning
alpha male
it's trending this morning
now I was thinking about it the kids had
Nick Adams I don't know if you ever
heard of this [ __ ] cuck he's a trump
cuck
it really he's pathetic but here's the
thing
I watched a few interviews
with the gentlemen
at Club Q
that took down the shooter
used his own [ __ ] weapon
the shooter's weapon
to beat the [ __ ] out of him
subduing
saved his family
saved his family's friends
just a damn shame
at that Maga terrorist
was able to get his hands on a weapon of
War
to kill five and injure dozens
before someone could take him down
but let me tell you something to all you
[ __ ] alpha males alpha males out
there
him
another kid now this is his story
and a trans woman
stop this [ __ ] from killing more
people
I I
can't believe they didn't just [ __ ]
kill him with their bare hands
to be quite honest
everyone's pissed off this morning that
that Adam kinzinger is talking about
punching Nazis hey let's do that [ __ ]
it's enough of this nonsense
you're gonna come and kill people for
who they are
you need you you should you should feel
the Thunder
I don't know if I would have quit
if I was
the person who was subduing him come in
try to kill our community try to [ __ ]
kill people because of who they are
that kind of intolerance is met with my
intolerance
I'm surprised that little fat [ __ ] made
it out alive
to be quite honest
this guy had military training
he didn't get he didn't draw a weapon
foreign
he what he wasn't wearing lifts in his
shoes
he didn't have dyed hair he didn't have
a a girdle on
he ran over there grabbed the guy's
[ __ ] weapon threw him down on the
ground and save people's lives that's a
[ __ ] alpha male
that's a [ __ ] alpha male no questions
didn't even question it
guy's gotta [ __ ] lap at a war ran
over to save he didn't care if he died
didn't give two shits
all he knew is this [ __ ] psychopath
it's my God Terrace with a goddamn gun
was gonna try to kill more people and
I'm sick and tired of the media saying
we don't know why he killed him [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you the media is
derelict in their Duty
they are doing a horrible [ __ ] job of
covering this shooting
horrible any [ __ ] media Outlet going
oh we're not really sure of his
motivation yet
you're stoking more violence is what
you're doing
you're part of the problem
it is clear what the motivations here
were
you don't have to look very far
[ __ ] just look at who raised that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
who groomed him to be a [ __ ] Maga
Mass shooter
and we're supposed to stand back and
listen to you
the national media well we're just the
facts aren't in yet
law enforcement hasn't
[ __ ] out of here we know why that
[ __ ] did what he did
you want me to tell you the reason
Tucker Carlson Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro
Maga
the America First Nazis Marjorie Taylor
green Lauren bobert you need more
[ __ ] reasons
Matt gatz
anyone with the [ __ ] R next to their
goddamn name on a ballot
that's the reason
that's the reason why he went in and
killed those people because they [ __ ]
love stochastic terrorism
they love to watch some fat little
[ __ ] Maga Trump humping white dude
grab a gun and go kill people that they
want that they don't want to exist
that way they don't have to take
responsibility for it they can just
laugh at it
Libs of tick tock cat turd Matt Walsh
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
I couldn't yell yesterday because I was
scared I was gonna lose my voice but God
damn it I want to lose my voice on this
one
sick of this nonsense
hating people stoking violence to kill
people you [ __ ] Tucker Carlson
you [ __ ]
going on your goddamn TV show thoughts
and prayers and we need to end violence
and then and then pinning up the entire
LGBT community as [ __ ] pedophiles in
in the next [ __ ] two minute segment
you piece of [ __ ] trash
everybody in this country knows who the
[ __ ] pedophiles and the [ __ ]
weirdos and chomos are
there's report after report after report
every [ __ ] day
white Christian sis dudes that's what it
is
trumped up [ __ ]
[ __ ] Trump himself oh I I love going
into the dressing room and watching
naked naked teenage girls
it's the thing I get to do
hanging out with Jeffrey Epstein
having Jeffrey Epstein Drive girls to
Mar-A-Lago yeah we know who it is
and got a guess
why do you think they're so [ __ ]
focused on it
it's all projection
all of it
and to try to drive a narrative in this
country
of so much hate
for a for a community that is so
marginalized
that most people who even love love and
have someone who is transgender in life
can't fully understand what that
person's going through
can't fully understand it
so what the [ __ ] is it your business
stay out of it [ __ ]
mind your own
if you got problems and you can't stop
doing [ __ ] that you're doing Matt Walsh
and you know frankly honestly I think if
we're going to investigate laptops we
start with Matt Getz and Matt Walsh the
mats
if we're going to investigate laptops I
think there was a lab he's always got
that laptop in front of him
with that stupid [ __ ] sticker on it
what's a woman and then you know what a
[ __ ] woman is
he wants to marry little girls he
definitely doesn't know what a [ __ ]
woman is
he'd have his ass kicked
by the trans woman who stopped the Maga
Mass shooter from killing more people
have his [ __ ] ass dumped in I bet
enough of this intolerance
we should not tolerate it [ __ ] them
not for the bigotry
enough of the terrorism
stand up for your community
even if you don't fully understand it I
don't fully understand it
but it's not for me to understand that's
the point
it's not for me to understand
you do not have to understand someone's
choices
to give them Liberty
you do not
thank you
and just because your religion or
whatever the [ __ ] your beliefs because
it's not an opinion you're [ __ ] you you
don't have opinions you have [ __ ]
beliefs there is a difference
opinions are Tethered to [ __ ] facts
and reality your beliefs are delusional
treating other human beings fellow human
beings like Monsters
like sub-human
it really does put you in a special kind
of [ __ ] category
and then every every turn we cannot
tolerate
they're [ __ ] bigotry
our liberty no matter who you are what
religion you are where you come from
where you were born
what your gender is what your skin color
is
what your political affiliation is your
Liberty depends
and relies
on the lgbtq community the bipod
community
women
receiving their Liberty it depends on it
and that's what they're trying to do
that's what the Matt Walsh is the bench
piros the Steve bannons the Donald
Trumps the Tucker Carlsons that's what
they're trying to do is convince you
that they'll come take your Liberty if
you don't take theirs
somehow somehow because someone wants to
identify a certain way takes away your
[ __ ] rights and it's the stupidest
[ __ ] I've ever heard in my life
and we need to stop the nonsense
why do I say this well you're going to
run into a bunch of dumb [ __ ] this week
you know what I'm talking about you got
them in your family
you know who I'm [ __ ] talking about
and a lot of you are going to have a
conversation at a table
and you're going to have someone at that
table allude to the fact
that they're disappointed that that
shooter didn't get off more shots
that's how far we've come with these
[ __ ] scumbags
with Fox News Daily wire these
[ __ ] vile pieces of [ __ ]
they've got brain rot on our country
and you're going to hear that nasty vile
[ __ ]
and you're gonna have to look them dead
in the eyes
and you're gonna have to tell them nope
nope nope not gonna tolerate that kind
of talk
you gross [ __ ]
we must stand up for them
we must
those fine that were killed and the 21
that were injured we must stand up for
them
just like just like the three people who
subdued the shooter inside the club we
must stand up for them
and they'll say oh it's
just trying to
trying to be bougie no
our Liberty depends on theirs
and they had it stolen away from them
ripped away
in a moment
because some [ __ ]
Tucker Carlson Matt Walsh type decided
he was gonna go take it into his own
hands
and go do what Tucker Carlson and Matt
Walsh had been secretly telling him to
do
that's right it's on their [ __ ] hands
I don't give a [ __ ] come after me you
[ __ ]
sue me [ __ ] Tucker Carlson Matt Walsh
you're responsible for this type of
terrorism you
Warren bobert you're responsible for
this type of terrorism Margaret Taylor
green you're responsible for this type
of terrorism Donald Trump you're
responsible for this type of terrorism
it's you
and the media needs to say it out loud
stop [ __ ] pussy-footing around
waiting on more facts to come in
don't need nothing else to come in we
know exactly what's happening everybody
it's Thanksgiving week
and it's Tuesday
you know here on Tuesday we have Texas
Paul and we have tacos and today it's
easy cheese Tuesday so
um last week I dropped the ball but this
Tuesday since it's Thanksgiving we're
gonna have a special Thanksgiving meal
uh slim jim tacos
it's gonna be awesome I promise we won't
do it like in the middle we'll do it
near the end that way if you're like and
I gotta bounce on the whole I gotta
mount to the old slim jim Taco thing
we'll do it towards the end we'll do it
towards the end I promise I promise but
Texas Paul is coming up
um we're going to talk to Texas Paul I
want to talk to him about this thing in
Arizona I'm really interested in his
thoughts on this
and and also I want to get his feeling
on what happened in Colorado Springs so
everyone stick around we'll be right
back with Texas well right after these
messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
oh it's Tuesday it's Thanksgiving
Tuesday we're gonna have a short week
this week Monday Tuesday Wednesday we're
gonna take Thursday Friday off
[Music]
maybe some ham mashed taters corn
[Music]
beans you know what my favorite thing to
do
is to take the corn and put it in the
mashed potatoes Texas ball I put them in
there and I mix them around
and I eat my mashed potatoes with corn
in it that's one of my that's I was here
making you a KFC bowl at the house hell
yeah hell yeah
hell yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah I mixed my food I mixed my
food
I'm so glad to be here Tony I just
wanted to tell you
there you go oh we're kicking it off
brother it's that time it is that time I
want you to have a wonderful
oh yeah brother I I'm looking forward to
the holidays this year I'm so glad to be
here with you I really am I know I I
know you're a family man and I want you
to have a wonderful holiday with your
family my friend oh I I tell you um
we've already got uh turkey bot
um we're making Blends I think it's
gonna be a small meal this year and
we're not gonna travel but um because
we're so used to not traveling I guess
the last few years that um we just kind
of make that a tradition I guess it's
become a tradition so but we're gonna
answer the those are the best ones
though man just you and the family hell
yeah yeah we gotta well we got a couple
friends that their their families are
out of town so they're gonna come visit
gonna come meet with us so that'll be
fun you know just a small little little
dinner we got the uh
got the rolls going get the you know and
yeah yeah yeah you know the good stuff
um my wife's gonna make a chocolate
lasagna you ever had chocolate lasagna
oh my God Texas ball sounds good though
yeah you take it she she takes Oreos and
she crests crushes them up puts them on
the bottom and then it's like uh pudding
whipped cream more chocolate pudding
more whipped cream chocolate chips on
the top oh maggot and then of course
we're gonna have pumpkin pie how can you
not have pumpkin pie
I
can't you got to have it you gotta have
it and I was going to throw in you know
my wife she's an amazing cook dude she
really she's just a she's just amazing
right now
baby I don't know I don't know she's in
the kitchen right now dude I got I've
got these smells wafting into my room
she's doing her pre-thanksgiving
stuff I mean because she's a hell of a
cook man she really is and and I told
her I said you know instead of instead
of doing the little the the little uh um
picking the blanket things that you do
with the little smokies let's go ahead
and make little slim jim tacos
she said I will kill you myself
I got my easy cheese ready today
the cheddar kind and I've got and and
speaking it smells wafting a food I can
smell the slim jim and the tortilla
sitting here so
um no I I I've been under the weather
it's gonna be I'm gonna tell you it's
going to be better than you expect it's
going to be I'll just give you that much
I I think I'm gonna enjoy it
I think I'm gonna enjoy it because at
what's not to like you get the tortilla
you get the slim jims and you got the
easy cheese what the hell else I mean
what else could you ask for really I'm
telling you and I've got it on a paper I
gotta confess I kind of liked it a
little bit I did I've got it on a paper
plate so it's it's all right here it's
all right here even on the paper plate
we've got Gabe Sanchez joining us
um what do you think Gabe did you grab
your Slim Jims and your easy cheese uh
no right not because I'm not a goddamn
villain
if I did it would be my villain origin
story everyone would know exactly how
evil Gabe was created it was cheese whiz
and slim jims and a tortilla all right
I'm telling you now I'm here to witness
amongst all of our viewers yeah you guys
eat this delicacy yeah for the record I
ate mine last week and my wife let me
eat another one my wife will not let me
eat another one she said no freaking way
you're not eating two of those Ricky
Taco was it that bad after the
Aftershock was it that bad the
Aftershock
no man it's actually not it's not about
I will tell you this I was shocked it
was not a bad Taco it wasn't there you
go you know it gave us very sorely
disappointed in Texas ball right now oh
my gosh so I I want to get the politics
Texas Paul give me your opinion because
um of course right now they're freaking
out in Arizona because they lost this
thing that's the one they wanted the
most because they had the biggest
election nighters in Arizona and I think
that's really why they wanted that one
the most because the AG race the AG race
has them freaking out they thought they
were going to hold the ages office and
they were going to be able to do all
this underhanded [ __ ] and no we won the
AG race in Arizona Arizona is now blue
it is now a blue State and they are
freaking the [ __ ] out I think what is it
Mojave and Cochise County
they're uh they're they're refusing to
certify which is a crime and and um Mike
Flynn Carrie Lake and others are the
ones in Steve Bannon of course are
trying to encourage this now let me see
if I can pull that video up while we're
talking about it
um and uh all right it's a it's a
[ __ ] felony these are federal
failings this is going to be sedition
here
um what they're trying to do yeah here
is um here's Mike Flynn talking about it
to I don't know who this [ __ ] guy is
um I don't know let's see you know who
this guy is game he looks like um
Pulitzer
obviously not a Pulitzer Prize winner
well probably not probably not uh he
looks like a nearsighted Proctologist
but
he's according to Google yeah he's a an
American entrepreneur
um what does that have to do with
elections no I don't know uh I look at
this look at this article from May of
2022 and it says Joven pulitzer's fraud
claims are utter rubbish so he's tried
this before it sounds like
um it looks like he tried this uh told
the Arizona Senate so this is yeah it
says okay so a researcher of the Arizona
hired a double check analysis of balance
by election conspiracy theorist Joven
Pulitzer said the claims that were
upwards of 12 000 counterfeit ballots
were utter rubbish so it looks like he
tried to do this in the 2020
presidential election
um
and was completely called out for it so
he's not just so he's not just um a
podcaster here doing a show with Mike
Flynn yeah no I mean this is one of the
guys that cost Arizona money to do these
recounts to pay the Cyber ninjas
by the way this afternoon just went
they're now defunct they don't exist
anymore
you know I got a Texas Paul take on that
GA I really do you know I and I know you
guys I know you guys
if somebody has a question
recount
you know let's let's keep let's keep it
legit let's do it you know you're
entitled to a recount what you're not
entitled to is to whole cloth just make
[ __ ] up yeah you know if you want to say
this doesn't look right to me
I as somebody that voted for the other
party am 100 behind you got questions
let's get answers yeah I want my I want
my democracy legit absolutely but just
making [ __ ] up whole cloth
and making these [ __ ] allegations
that are just ridiculous not not hey I
got a question but you did this and you
did that and I know they were some crazy
[ __ ] going on in Maricopa County and
this hadn't it it doesn't make sense
because you know they just brought in
ballots okay now that's crossing the
[ __ ] line you've just made an
allegation now yeah you have made an
allegation Which nut balls will listen
to
and believe because you're telling them
what they want to hear and that's where
it crosses the [ __ ] line that's where
we get these fat [ __ ] terrorists and
Club Q because
they listen to the [ __ ] and believe it
they don't think that somebody would
really sit here like we are you know and
you know you've heard me say it there is
something [ __ ] wrong in these Texas
numbers I have questions but I have
never said the voting machine stole your
your your votes I've never said you know
you're not going for election officials
to to not certify either right I mean no
no I'm saying you're also not calling
for the death of election officials
[ __ ] ain't right I think that's
another story the other election
officials had to go into hiding right
right and and not I mean like Arizona is
a cesspool of conspiracy theories
especially like ever since the 2020
election it's just like a [ __ ] of
conspiracies and right-wing nuts but I
mean also Arizona let's keep in mind
what they did they took election data
sent it to their uh well how did they
phrase it it was their uh their secure
lab which was really the cabin in
Montana to the CEO of the Cyber ninjas
like there's a lot of like it seems a
little weird that if you're gonna do
this recount totally fine I don't know
why you can't do it in the location
which is Arizona you have to send it off
to this secure lab only to be called out
for double Counting
and not actually showing that your
candidate that you wanted to win
actually did win they actually found out
that they had less votes in the recount
and there were more votes for for Biden
less votes for Trump and more votes for
Biden because typically in a recount
you'll you'll see you'll see yeah let's
do it count well here let me show this
video of what Mike Flynn is alleging
here and this is wild [ __ ] and it's not
surprising coming from Mike Flynn let's
listen so one County cannot allow its
citizens to be disenfranchised because
of the because of the laziness or the uh
or the or the lack of sort of certifying
properly of an election in another
County if one County looks at their
results and they say hands down Kerry
Lake wanted to governorship and hands
down Mark fincham wanted hands down Lake
Masters one for the for the U.S Senate
by like more than 50 or more than 100
margins you cannot certify an election
unless all votes are counted fair and
honestly right that means all counties
so if one even one county says we we
don't think we can certify because we
have problems with our election systems
this is really weird [ __ ] how he's over
100 margin over 100 percent
if you see results for over 100 percent
that's uh
I think what he's saying I think what
he's saying here I think what he's
saying here is that hey there's one
County in Arizona where they voted
overwhelming with Kerry Lake and that
means Carrie Lake won and then there's
another County that that voted
underwhelmingly for Cary lake so but it
still means she won because this one
County but I mean it just doesn't make
any sense but it's not supposed to
that's the point it's not supposed to
make sense this [ __ ] is not supposed to
be Tethered to reality we were talking
about this yesterday Gabe and I'm going
to keep pounding this drum with these
[ __ ] moglodytes is that there is this
is not an opinion Mike Flynn with this
nonsense as he's talking about this is
not an opinion yeah it is not Tethered
to reality it's not Tethered to facts
it's not an opinion it is a belief it's
delusional it's it's [ __ ] vile it's
dangerous but it's not an opinion it's a
belief so stop with your [ __ ]
[ __ ] either either get with the
facts and and get there or don't and
shut the [ __ ] up and move on and really
that's what's gonna happen here is not
only that they're not going to be able
to stop the certification to double to
double down on what Texas ball said yeah
like
what's wrong with the recount let's do
it right and not only that this is the
same group that was like we don't like
electronic ballots we want them hand
done we want them hand counted we want
you to make sure you guys made these
rules you made the rules why it's taken
slower right why it's taking longer and
now that you got the results and it
turns out when you did count them by
hand and you made sure that that was
actually how the ballots were that they
[ __ ] laid out
you get mad because you're candidate
lost and now that your candidate loss
you say well I don't accept the results
but you should accept them because they
were done under the conditions that you
bitched and moaned about especially
after the 2020 election because they're
like oh no no these machines and this
count we got to cure These Fine [ __ ]
recount them cure the balance do what
you need to do
but at the end of the day you're not
gonna find that your candidate actually
won and one county is not going to
overwhelmingly throw off a race to say
oh you know what Carrie Lake actually
won because this one County was over a
hundred percent like what the [ __ ] is
that they don't make any sense and they
they can't pick a lane it's either keep
counting stop counting whoa whoa whoa
there's fraud in the water like
it doesn't make any sense and I mean not
that not that anyone should obviously
think that they can make sense because
it's the Republican party and everything
they say is completely incompetent and
[ __ ] ass backwards so so Texas Paul
here is uh Nicole Griggs she's a
reporter out in Arizona she says
Happening Now Mojave I think that's one
of the ones you mentioned County Board
of Supervisors is discussing the
possibility of delaying certification of
the midterm elections results in Mojave
as a sign of solidarity after what
happened in Maricopa County which
doesn't make any sense Mark Elias
um who they are terrified of by the way
uh Marco and there's good reason because
he knows the law and he's really good at
this I don't know election stuff
um Mark Elias says let me be clear if
any Arizona county fails to follow the
law and to timely certify the election
results they will be sued the board
members in Mojave
um should go ask their buddies
um and what is cohes is that how you say
it Go cheese goat cheese uh about how
the work how that worked out for them so
um Mark Elias sending shots across the
bow here daring them to not certify
these elections because the courts
aren't going to let them not certify
these elections that's the thing that's
going to happen here
yeah and to back up what what Gabe said
just a minute ago you know you know they
know they're full of [ __ ] because
they're very carefully choosing verbiage
like well the percentage well there are
counties in Texas and Arizona where
there are like 10 people in them you
know I mean since there's nobody in
these [ __ ] counties and they all vote
for [ __ ] Trump I don't know what
about being a [ __ ] lonely [ __ ]
person in the desert why it makes you a
[ __ ] Trump voter but it does okay and
these Counties have [ __ ] outrageous
percentages for [ __ ] Trump and and
and for the Republicans in general and
they want to sit there and say [ __ ] like
well the percentages in these counties
are different from the percentages than
these guys well guess what Maricopa
County is a [ __ ] Phoenix people
this has Phoenix is not an all-white all
white all white City it's not it's a
diverse City
it is you have you have Hispanics in
Phoenix you have first people in Phoenix
you have black folks in Phoenix you have
white folks in Phoenix this is not your
[ __ ] mother's [ __ ] milk white milk
toast [ __ ] City it's not and they're
saying well Maricopa County well yeah of
course Maricopa County votes like a real
[ __ ] County wood that has real
[ __ ] people in it you know and
they're like well they're you know you
look at this County and it just throws
everything off well the [ __ ] yeah it
does people actually live there
you know you've got Pima County uh uh
that that has has
um
[ __ ] I'm Tongue Tied let me pull my map
up Pima County that's that that's uh
got Tucson in it you've got Phoenix
Maricopa County that's got Phoenix in it
you know these counties are going to go
overwhelmingly blue they just are
because they are real [ __ ] cities
there and everybody knows that when you
have a city where people actually have
to live together you don't get a lot of
[ __ ] dicks in those cities because
people have to get along
you can go out in the [ __ ] Woods like
a hillbilly and be a [ __ ] dick all
day long and nobody will ever know
because they're not there to like
[ __ ] hear it you know when it when
when uh
[ __ ] snowflake hillbilly melts in the
woods the question is did it really melt
because there's nobody [ __ ] there to
hear it
you know
I don't know what you're talking about
tell me where I'm wrong
I agree I want to show you something
here speaking of this uh counties and
[ __ ] um because this is a another
question another state Nevada uh our
friend Keith Troy blue did a video on
this I said Troy explains how population
Works to the [ __ ] eaters
um this is a perfect example of what
you're talking about like people living
in this desert when there's like just a
handful of people in the county watch
this after every [ __ ] election we got
to explain population density to
Republicans so if you look at this map
of Nevada and you think it's a red State
because of all this this red area
colored in here let me explain a couple
things to you this entire [ __ ] County
right here is literally one dude he
works for the Bureau of Land Management
and his literal only [ __ ] job is to
sit in the desert and count how many
Native toads are eaten by native
javelinas and he lives in a tent on top
of a Jeep on top of a giant sand dune
that was purposely put there by the
government to hide a nuclear waste
storage facility but tent lizard guy
also happens to be an incel who just
lost ten thousand dollars on his crypto
investment and he has posters of Elon
musk's in the tent so he votes
Republican which means this entire
[ __ ] County where 10 lizard guy is
the only guy that entire county is red
because he voted Republican meanwhile
this is Clark County the home of
fabulous Las Vegas with a population of
650 000 people and they vote mostly
Democrat so Clark County is blue so to
review this County one guy sitting in
the desert eating peyote
this County
650 thousand
but also voting Democrat is that does
that clear it up that's why that's why
this is actually a blue State because
and Troy does such a great job here of
explaining how population works
the the really I mean like uh
I kind of wanted him to show the
population density map because those are
a good representation to show you how
tiny little red specks are in these
random places like Montana and Wyoming
and Utah and it's just it just spread
out of all white tiny red dots and you
might have other areas across different
states that are bigger red populations
that have mine a bigger bubble but then
for all these other ones you're seeing
huge blue bubbles huge blue bubbles
medium blue bubbles medium blue bubbles
that's the population and that's showing
you giving you an idea that when you
look at the map when you look at the
United States in these in these counties
and these different states across the
country that it's actually not you know
you're not always oh that's a red State
because for the point that he that he
made which is just one dude in the
middle of the desert [ __ ] jerking it
to Elon Musk saying my vote counts and
then he does what he does best and you
know he loses so stop the skin
it's it is it is kind of funny that
that's like the um you know they just
they walk right into this it's
stereotypical of these I mean you think
for a bunch of people it's like when you
try to understand or but yeah when you
try to understand the logic of like a
flat earther or someone who's trying to
explain how a flat earth works and
you're like all right let's run an
experiment and even though they see it
before themselves and they say oh that
the Earth
even you know they they acknowledge
you're like oh this experiment proves
the Earth is round but I don't accept it
I still think it's flat you know do you
think do you think tent lizard guy is a
flat earther oh yeah for sure if you
look if he looks across the Wasteland of
of the sand he says it's flat it looks
like I can't see I can't see the bend of
the earth and I look at the same way
like this people who deny elections and
are unwilling to understand or at least
admit how population density impacts
voting
are there the same people as the flat
earthers I'm just gonna go on I'm just
gonna call they're the same people
same [ __ ] yeah what do you
think Paul you think you think tent
lizard gang is probably a flat earther
I think that dude has done so much
peyote that he would believe anything
that you would tell him if you brought a
Snickers bar I mean
100 but you know yeah go ahead go ahead
something you were saying earlier too
about punch a [ __ ] Nazi applies here
it really applies here we I have a
problem in this country we have huge
chunks of police departments look I love
cops I come from a cop family
I do I Love College okay
but I will tell you they will tell you
there are huge [ __ ] problems in in
PDS they really are these [ __ ] crazy
ass right-wing bastards
are full up in these PDS they are
they're not going to handle this for us
they aren't and I'll give you my own
personal story okay my own personal
punching Nazi story just happened the
other day in Sam's parking lot
you have to stand up people you have to
and I've apologized to my wife profusely
for this so don't be ragging on me okay
but we're putting our groceries away in
the back of the car
this guy behind me I noticed he is
literally in a beat up old piece of [ __ ]
pickup truck with a [ __ ] Trump
sticker on the back
is inches away from the truck in front
of him I look up in the truck and this
old man gets out I'm talking about not
50 years old not 60s old not I'm talking
about you know humped over shoulders
walks real slow old 80s 90s you know
what I mean he gets out of the passenger
seat I look in the in the driver's seat
and there isn't a woman his age driving
him because she can see I guess you know
they're waiting on a handicap space up
the way I'll make this short I will the
guy's backing up in and out of the space
you know how they are in Sam's the
handicap space faces straight and then
the others are angled right well this
guy keeps backing up into the handicap
space because she can't park well this
[ __ ] Trumper is having a conniption
fit that she's taking
90 seconds out of his [ __ ] day to
park this truck and you know everybody
drives pickup trucks here she's got
they've got a beautiful GMC truck I mean
you could tell she's not real
comfortable driving this [ __ ]
behemoth so she's really waiting and she
goes to pull into that space after the
[ __ ] that up there quits messing
around and blocking her she goes to pull
into that space and Trumper pulls up
next to her doesn't go about his
business after wasting you know being so
livid about his day being wasted pulls
up next to her rolls his window down and
starts screaming obscenities at her and
honking his horn
I lost it dude I mean you know when you
lose time I don't know if you've ever if
you've never engaged in violence you
don't understand losing time
it's like one minute I was next to my
wife and the next minute I was bolting
across the [ __ ] parking lot screaming
at this [ __ ] move your [ __ ]
ass I mean I'm just losing it in this
parking lot everybody and you know I got
a voice man
everybody in the parking lot's [ __ ]
watching this my wife is dying inside
because I'm chasing a [ __ ] he hears
me coming sees my big ass running across
the park he's gone dude I'm chasing the
[ __ ] Trumpeter across the parking lot
shit's going down oh man and and I
freaked everybody out because nobody
knew that they thought I was yelling
about the traffic jam I was and I was
yelling because this guy is [ __ ]
being abusive to an elderly woman
trying to get into a goddamn handicap
space and too many people let that [ __ ]
go
too many people watched that [ __ ] happen
not anymore not anymore they're like
well you could have got shot shoot me
[ __ ] that's what it's gonna cost
you you want to yell at an old lady in
my presence you're gonna have to [ __ ]
shoot me and I will throw [ __ ] hands
on you and I guarantee you I am glad
that guy hauled ass I really am because
I was in the [ __ ] Zone man I was not
in reality
I wasn't you know and I stopped I'm
standing in the middle of [ __ ]
traffic right in front of Sam's got
everything blocked
but you know and I turned around and I
walked up to the lady I'm like hey I'm
sorry you know I'm sorry I had to see
that I'm really proud of you for
standing up to that bully and she smiled
at me and waved
but I'm telling you that's the [ __ ]
problem that's why they do this [ __ ] in
Arizona because they think there's no
[ __ ] cost to it make it cost them
make it cost them [ __ ] everything
everything to do this
so just my humble two cents worth you
were saying um um bringing a punching
Nazis I was referring earlier to uh
everyone's really upset that Adam
kinzinger is uh they say he's you know
threatening violence against cat turd
I'm not [ __ ] you that is a [ __ ]
sentence I have to say
um that Adam kinziger is threatening by
myself yeah I saw I saw catcher training
earlier and I was like what's this and
then it was every right wing [ __ ]
person he like they're threatening so
here's what I said I said not not
against Adam kinzinger or anyone else
punching Nazis because here's what he
said and I'll show you the rest the the
art quote unquote that he was responding
to and kenzinger and this tweet is
unavailable I don't know Twitter's
[ __ ] up or something
but I've had I've had to reload this
several times just to show you this oh
um there's something crazy going on with
I I've had trouble so far I don't know
there
um there might be I don't know if
there's like the three people holding
the bailing twine together they ran out
of duct tape at [ __ ] [ __ ] amazing
you fired all your employees and your
[ __ ] falls apart who you thought yeah
um but Adam kinsicker um responded to
cat turds art
Jesus Christ I can't even believe I have
to say that sentence Adam kinzinger a
sitting [ __ ] congressman
quote tweets cat turds art Jesus Christ
okay he says literal evil
if I met you in person it would not end
well for you sicko trolls you have never
done anything in their life pretend to
be Patriots and laugh at real Warriors
okay so this has to do with Ukraine all
right
um and this is really a really stupid
[ __ ] take and really honestly I feel
the same way Adam I don't agree with
Adam kinsinger a lot not a lot I just
don't he's he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] box Adam
kinzinger is no [ __ ] liberal
democracy hero here but I agree with him
on this point I
would probably do [ __ ] if I was within
spitting distance of cat turd but here
it says it's dumb and I'm laughing
here's the [ __ ] art
literally uh about Ukraine now
right now in Ukraine
um they're they've got Russia on their
heels uh Russia was supposed to go in in
three hours and take Ukraine zielinski
was supposed to be killed months ago the
guy's still Standing Tall I think he's
been through three
UK prime ministers at this point
but here here it shows that Ukraine is
crying and pissing themselves yeah okay
number one this is [ __ ] just absolute
misinformation this meme is completely
untrue it is the opposite of what is
happening in Ukraine
um they are they got Russia pissing
their pants and crying but obviously cat
turd is a Nazi uh it's pretty simple cat
turds a Nazi I mean why would Elon Musk
give them more time of day than not if
he wasn't a Nazi I mean well I mean why
would he bring people back like Donald
Trump marger Taylor green uh uh project
Veritas project Veritas but then also
today I don't know if you saw this
they're banning actual groups that are
helping those that are protecting lgbtq
communities wait so they're taking their
accounts down yeah so let me uh I'll
find this Christ of course of course
they are
um why you're doing that I want to to
see if I can find
one of the news reports because I I'm
I'm assuming that they're trying to uh
um get rid of this guy on
let's see if I can find it what you're
talking about while you look that up
what's going on in Ukraine folks need to
know Joe Biden's a smart [ __ ] he
really is he is not dumb he is not dumb
he is a smart [ __ ] and I am
telling you right now every weapon
systems that we have given Ukraine they
before the next Congress is seated they
are absolutely giving them as much
ammunition as possible
um they
Ukraine is is go is stacked enough right
now to fight for the rest of these for
another year
they Russia is [ __ ] and I don't give a
damn how much these russia-loving [ __ ]
think that they're going to turn around
and [ __ ] the Ukraine who's fighting for
their
own land their own liberty
you know you've got this piece of [ __ ]
Putin [ __ ] invading them and you got
these right-wing [ __ ] that's what I'm
telling you you cannot let this go
without a cost
if somebody [ __ ] says to you in front
of your face
[ __ ] the Ukraine you know I I support
[ __ ] Putin how about you backslap
that [ __ ]
how about that
you want to be a [ __ ] traitor
[ __ ] you want to [ __ ] over
people that we're helping we're
supporting save their own goddamn
country from an invasion from our enemy
news flash Russia's always been our
[ __ ] enemy and I don't care how many
times [ __ ] Tucker Carlson and Chad go
over there and suck his dick that's it
they're our [ __ ] enemy they will [ __ ]
our geopolitical goals at every [ __ ]
turn people and you get a traitor in
front of you saying hey you know what
let's let's Force Ukraine to the peace
table and this that and the other how
about I just [ __ ] back [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of you back Jack slap the [ __ ] out
of you
and you go on about your day I mean also
because you know if you look at the GOP
they claim to be the pro-life party but
they are totally okay with Putin
committing genocide against innocent
people women children hospitals you know
we are
271 days into this
this Ukraine Russia conflict War you
know however you want to describe it uh
we are three months shy of it being a
year you know they everyone thought you
know Putin claimed ah we'll you know
we'll go through and it'll be a mere
hours 12 hours or less
we're only a few months away from 12
months a year a literal year we've been
dealing with this and Republicans as
much as they are pro-life they do not
care about human life
we've seen it through abortion we've
seen in a you know everything that you
can name across the table we've seen
about gun violence mass shootings they
don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] [ __ ] it even
goes down to their own mind
like like forced stabilization at the
border yep and here's here's more of it
now this is a hero here
um this is one of the gentlemen the main
gentleman that um took down the mass
Maga Mass shooter
uh the terrorist at Club Q he's a he's a
veteran but he describes here in this
interview outside his house here of how
he took him down listen to this I
grabbed him by the back of his little
cheap ass armor thing and I pulled him
down
the young man that was that was late he
was hiding there had jumped up with me I
don't know if he helped pull me to hold
him down or not I have no idea okay that
guy did the same act I amazing
pull the Dude down pin him against the
side and just start or I think he went
for his pistol I don't know either way I
grabbed the pistol from him and then I
told the guy moved to AR the kid in
primies he was at his head I said move
the AR get the AR away from him and the
kid did it and then I started wailing on
this dude and I'm on top of him I'm a
big dude man and this guy was bigger and
I I just kept wailing on him and I told
the kid in front of me kick him in his
head keep kicking him in his head I'm
yelling 9-1-1 somebody call 9-1-1 and
I'm beating this guy this guy's trying
to wiggle he's trying to get his ammo
his guns one of the the performers uh
walked by or was running by and I told
her kick this guy kick this guy and she
took her high heel and stuffed it in his
face
or his head or whatever she could hit
obviously
um you know the details are kind of
sparse here just because this is um a
situation where
um it was a fast act right they had to
act fast
um Gabe and Paul I want to get your
opinions on this I got to take a quick
break because I need to do a coughing
break yeah
um so give me just a minute you guys
talk about this clip and talk about uh
Club Q because I know it's it's
something you guys probably want to talk
about so I'll be right back but you guys
go ahead and
I mean it really it really does show you
you know uh
it puts down the idea that the good guy
with the gun can take down the bad guy
with a gun I mean even you know there's
that there's the petty side in me right
now knowing exactly who took him down
someone who is trans took down this guy
who went in to kill
trans people as well as anyone else in
the LGBT community right like
we know
the Republican Party pushes this idea
other other people within the Republican
Party push the idea that trans or in
lgbtq or groomers and this and that it's
all projection
so then when you find out these details
of who actually did it it was a veteran
they don't want to they don't want to
give acknowledgment they don't want to
acknowledge that person it was a trans
person as well they don't want to
acknowledge they don't want to give
credit they want to say oh [ __ ] these
are actual Heroes right all it is is
empty thoughts and prayers all it is as
well the real problem is these clubs and
then you've got you know Tony and I
talked about yesterday you've got people
like Matt Walsh who try to make a apples
and oranges uh numbers comparison and
say Well they're actually less debts
within the trans Community than there
are those of the general population as
if that's anywhere close in comparison
but of course the Republican party will
do whatever they can to to make their
argument uh regardless of how they
cherry pick the facts and the numbers
yeah and and think about that they where
did they feel like they had to defend
and who did they feel like they had to
attack I mean let me tell you something
first of all I'm not shocked that a
trans drag performer kicked the [ __ ] out
of this some [ __ ] I'm not one of my
good friends growing up Jimmy was it was
his openly gay pink hair I mean you're
talking about in the middle of [ __ ]
hillbilly bill this dude has pink
frosted hair and takes cosmetology when
the rest of us are in [ __ ] diesel
mechanics you know what I'm saying this
dude
would kick your ass because he's been
fighting his whole life right you know I
mean I would throw hands but I wouldn't
[ __ ] with Jimmy because Jimmy would kick
your ass man you know because he's had
to his whole life and
this just affirms what couple things
they're terrified of here this just
absolutely [ __ ] affirms reality over
narrative you think your gun is going
going to make give you the advantage
chances are you're going to [ __ ] die
with your own gun [ __ ] Mr Fiero there
pick this guy's [ __ ] pistol he tried
to pull his pistol out and save himself
he took his [ __ ] pistol away and beat
him in the [ __ ] head with it he's
lucky Fiero didn't take and just
right you know he's really [ __ ] lucky
all of these all of these guys who go
into these situations they read enough
[ __ ] 4chan and these forums are
watching Tucker cross and the great
replacement Theory all of these things
they're listening to Matt Walsh saying
how trans people in the LGBT community
are trying to groom them you've got
little politicians who are using their
time taxpayer money to tweet out
messages hateful messages against a a a
a a marginalized Community a community
that continues to every day have to
prove themselves whether they're they're
of uh of color or they're of uh you know
of a certain uh sexual whatever like
whatever it might be they're a Target
and especially if you're on if you cross
over in both those categories double
down on that you're a Target because
people don't like you for the skin the
color of your skin or the way that you
[ __ ]
truly feel who you are right whether
you're a man woman trans you're you're
you're non-binary you don't identify as
this or that like whatever you might be
who the [ __ ] cares because it's none of
their [ __ ] business but they make it
their business and they make your life
your literal life as to how you live or
die their [ __ ] business and they
broadcast it to the the rest the rest of
the [ __ ] world and there's actually a
tweet I'm gonna I just sent you Tony and
you know along what you're saying there
[ __ ] Aldrich there didn't have to get
it from anywhere he got it at home from
[ __ ] Paw Paw who is Randy vocal right
down in San Diego down in your neck of
the woods go stop that [ __ ] I'm
telling you that old bastard sit there
and [ __ ] turn this kid into a
terrorist he turned him into a [ __ ]
and you know what else to who else did
you want to talk about drag shows and
trans people [ __ ] your churches [ __ ]
your [ __ ] churches because his past
is the one that [ __ ] radicalized him
they show go back and watch [ __ ]
his Pastor talk and his church about
[ __ ] and the Republicans their
response to this today still two [ __ ]
day their response is well if there
weren't [ __ ] trans people we wouldn't
be [ __ ] them would we right
literally their [ __ ] defense why I
mean that's that's that's that's the
[ __ ] the cruelty is the point I mean
it is it truly is the point when they're
demonizing people listen
the marginalized community of lgbtq
people have been being called monsters
for a long time by the religious
community there's a there's a
organization out there called the
American Family Association sounds great
right sounds great AFA they have all
kinds of [ __ ] radio shows and
Christian talk shows and their entire
apparatus
and this goes back almost 20 years have
been calling people in the LGBT
community Monsters uh demons uh
pedophiles uh um they talk about them
[ __ ] animals I mean all kinds of
weird ass [ __ ] that these people
propagate all this misinformation about
that community and it's all to stoke
fear into a little a little terrorist
heart like we have here right that's the
whole purpose but what we've always got
to have another they've always got to
have another to attack there's always
got to be a bad thing right that's right
well and
um this is
um the same guy who took down the gunman
um he's describing it on another news
program
um but I think it's important to watch
this one because not only does he
describe
him taking down but he describes the
moment why he's there
why it's so significant let's watch it
it may not even been a window left but I
saw a lot of people and this guy was
there and I saw the ACU pattern uh like
this and for me that was like there's a
handle I'm getting it so I ran across
the room grabbed the handle pulled him
down and then started to uh well
actually I think I went for his gun with
him his rifle flew in front of him
um and the young man that tried to jump
in there with me
um he he we both either pulled him down
or whatever but he ended up at his head
uh and right next to the AR
and then with the AR he we I told him
push the AR get the area away from him
the kid pushed the AR I I don't know
what his name was
um and then I I proceeded to take his
other weapon the pistol and then just
start hitting him where I could with the
Armor's in the way and I just started I
found a crease in his between his his
armor and his head and I just started
wailing away uh with his gun
um and then I told the kid in front of
me kick him keep kicking him and we were
I was yeah I was guided I was telling
people call 9-1-1 call 9-1-1 I brought
him down I I
I was in mode I was I was doing what I
did I do downrange you know I trade I
trained for this I don't want to ever do
this I I didn't even retire because I
was just I was done doing this stuff it
was too much and uh I I'm you know it
came in handy and and I got to protect
my my kid I lost my kid's boyfriend I
tried I tried to have everybody in there
I still feel bad that there's five
people
okay
there's five people that didn't go home
and it's
this way I I told him while I was dating
him I said I'm gonna kill you man
because you try to kill me
[Music]
my family was in there
my little girl was in there with her we
are so sorry
if any manga is looking at that laughing
or like oh there should have been more
you need to be punched because you're a
Nazi it's just a simple fact it's enough
of this garbage where we're gonna We're
not gonna [ __ ] ACT stand around and
act like we should tolerate you and give
you your little your little position
that you think's an opinion it's not an
opinion it's a belief it's a vile gross
[ __ ] belief
and we're not going to tolerate your
nonsense anymore you can have your
beliefs but if you act on them or you
speak them out we you will pay
consequences in our society and you
should pay consequences in our society
and honestly I'm surprised that this guy
didn't just kill that little son of a
[ __ ] didn't just kill him with his bare
hands
um and it sounds like the only reason
why he didn't kill him with his bare
hands because he did have some cheap ass
body armor that he probably bought off
the internet
actually the reason you haven't seen
this kid is because they damn near did
they damn near dude rightfully so they
damn near beat this guy to death they
beat him with his own [ __ ] pistol you
know he got raffle stomped with high
heels [ __ ] yeah
amen amen I I'm sorry
I am sorry that is not a pleasant
feeling
total antithesis to what message is that
my wife wants me to spread right now
which is have a happy holidays folks but
no there's five [ __ ] people that
don't get to go see their family and eat
turkey right they don't get to be with
their [ __ ] friends and eat the corn
and mashed potatoes that I was talking
about earlier
they don't they don't get to go to three
different [ __ ] places over the
weekend and have leftover turkey
sandwiches or turkey and noodles
they don't get to [ __ ] be with their
families because this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] believe the garbage that Tucker
Carlson and Matt Walsh spew
and and I'll be damned if I'm gonna sit
here and act like well we just got to
put up with this [ __ ] [ __ ] that we do
not have to put up with this [ __ ] any
longer you don't have to tolerate this
[ __ ] garbage of Tucker Carlson Matt
Walsh stoking stochastic terrorism
they're the littlest dick [ __ ]
in the world they really are if they've
got you five to one they'll throw with
you they will they'll throw hands with
you but if you you take on smack one of
these [ __ ] upside their head I
guarantee he will cry like a little
[ __ ] he will he will cry like a little
[ __ ] there are very few people in this
country thank God that actually engage
in violence and I will tell you as
someone feel free to take check out the
scars I've got my [ __ ] battles card I
will tell you I will [ __ ] throw hands
with you don't pull that [ __ ] Market
[ __ ] with me will you come up and
you want to give me your [ __ ] opinion
you want to give me your opinion you
better be [ __ ] polite you be rude to
me you be rude to my wife and I will
[ __ ] put this [ __ ] fist in your
[ __ ] mouth before you're done that is
the price you will pay but I'm telling
you people oh I don't think it's an
opinion their beliefs they're not
opinions anymore we gotta stop calling
them opinions because it's not an
opinion your opinion that this person is
sub-human is not based in any kind of
fact to reality it is based in your
delusion and your [ __ ] that you've
been [ __ ] mind [ __ ] with with Matt
Walsh and Tucker Carlson uh Leslie
double seven here and says gay people
aren't shooting up straight nightclubs
black people shooting up white grocery
stores Latinos are not shooting up
Walmarts Jewish people are not shooting
up Christian churches the violence is
coming from one demographic alt-right
radicalized men and their white alt alt
white
radicalized men every [ __ ] time Nancy
Pelosi's husband Bob Pelosi this
[ __ ] every single every single
[ __ ] one that gets thwarted by the
FBI I mean there's hundreds of these
sons of [ __ ] that have been arrested
because they're making threats on social
media and they catch them in the act of
threatening and buying weapons and and
doing threats this is all [ __ ] this is
all [ __ ] done by by a set group of
people Steve Bannon Tucker Carlson my
Matt Walsh Fox News oan Newsmax daily
wire you [ __ ] are responsible
for this [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] responsible for this
garbage and until we as a country just
say nope not gonna happen not gonna
happen and and when and when a
[ __ ] comes in a grocery store or
when a [ __ ] comes in somewhere
with a gun you do whatever you can to
save however many lives you can save you
just do it because it it is a thing if
they if they think if they know even if
people ain't got guns they're still
gonna [ __ ] beat me to an inch of my
life maybe it'll make them think
probably not they're [ __ ] stupid but
I I just I can't tell you how [ __ ]
sick and tired I am of hearing this
garbage
um that and and then and then uh
like Lauren bobert saying thoughts and
prayers that pisses me off even more
well the thing also it's like you look
at Lauren bober for example she says
thoughts and prayers and she says you
know get your kids in church keep them
away from drag clubs or whatever
honestly my kids might be safer in a
[ __ ] drag club and if that
unfortunate situation happens like it
did over the past this weekend like yeah
I look at I look at kids and and
families that go well [ __ ] man they're
not safe in a school they're not safe in
a grocery store the place that you hate
where these where you don't want people
to go that you think is a [ __ ] sin in
a stain on society is actually the place
that [ __ ] stopped this shooter and
yes five people did die and another 17
are also people who were injured and may
not be able to go home because they're
in the hospital and I don't know what
long-term effects that has on them
whether emotionally or physically not
only that but even listening to the
interview that we had that we looked at
yesterday from that one person that I
was at the club who's like I wasn't even
supposed to be here
this weekend I was supposed to be in
Denver
but I came to the club to celebrate my
birthday and hang out with friends this
was the only safe place that we could go
for this community
and now you look at that community and
they say I mean yeah we are strong and
we're resilient and just like Texas Paul
said earlier his friend is [ __ ]
tougher than Nails than anyone else in
comparison because they have to [ __ ]
fight and Claw to make sure that people
actually respect and acknowledge them
right that say yes I am a person I am a
human being I am a I am a real human
here in this country and you I I have
the same [ __ ] rights as you do you
are not better than I you're probably
worse because of the things that you
believe and the fact that you say that
I'm not real right I don't count I don't
exist
and now you've got this community that
has to work even harder to repair the
damage and the pain that they've just
gone through
because now you know yeah this place
that was safe where people could enjoy
themselves and be whoever they [ __ ]
wanted to be now has to worry
that that they are another Target
that there's a there's a there's this
there's this dark kind of cloud that
sits over Colorado Springs because some
[ __ ] small dick no balls right wing
Tucker Carlson
Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh [ __ ] cuck
decides oh you know what I'm gonna take
what they said online and I'm gonna put
into action
[ __ ] that [ __ ] all of these
[ __ ] have blood on their hands
all of them every single one new station
you're [ __ ] pundit you're a [ __ ]
you know right-wing troll on Twitter
trying to make jokes about oh look at
this this is so [ __ ] funny go [ __ ]
yourselves
because if you really were pro-life and
you really didn't care about human life
they really didn't care about being a
[ __ ] Patron American
then you [ __ ] call this [ __ ] out but
because you want to joke and you want to
say Oh that's oh no other guys guys
that's not me that's this party but I
still associate with this party you're
[ __ ] Nazi too
you're a [ __ ] Nazi at the end of the
day I don't [ __ ] care you could say
whatever you [ __ ] want you're [ __ ]
Nazi and you're a [ __ ] coward
damn man we got gay man you gotta better
myself [ __ ] yeah oh yeah yeah man Gabe's
normally the one that that like you know
he's like the Mayo to our jalapeno man
he's he's I it's like as much as we want
a joke I'm just [ __ ] tired of this
[ __ ] man like the 2022
like we we thought going through Uvaldi
would have been some wake-up call
except you have Republicans who want to
say well the real way to change this
guys is one [ __ ] door in and out
that's how we're gonna do it we got to
add more security we got to add more
veterans and people who have PTSD give
them guns and put them in a school high
stress High [ __ ] tense environment
yeah think of a problem
think about all those I'm a badass DPS
Troopers down here in Texas and I'm a
badass Uvalde cops and this that and the
other that sat [ __ ] outside while he
murdered people well that [ __ ] just
shot people and they could hear it one
right after the other and didn't do a
[ __ ] thing and you care that I will
always for the rest of my life call them
Mr Fiera
Mr Fiero Gratz snatched that
[ __ ] up and ended it that [ __ ]
had enough ammunition to kill everybody
in that club and would have
and I guarantee you it was one Brave
individual that led the charge that that
brought this together and
you know I'm tired of it too Gabe I'm
tired of it too let's call it the way it
is [ __ ] your church
you [ __ ] your boy scouts they're [ __ ]
raping kids and the Boy Scouts they're
[ __ ] raping kids in churches they're
[ __ ] my church the Catholic church I
point one finger I point three fingers
back at me man the Catholic church is
[ __ ] man and you want to talk about
let me tell you something about it I
happen to know a few gay people I happen
to know a few people that are trans and
I'm telling you they put up with [ __ ]
abuse their whole lives and they are
radically against [ __ ] sexual
assaults and [ __ ] like that that is a
community that they will I guarantee you
these these women will [ __ ] beat your
ass
for [ __ ] with a kid I will guarantee
you my kid is safer in a drag Club than
he is in your [ __ ] Church
so the next time you you know Mr Mrs I'm
I'm better than everybody Christian you
go to church you walk into that big
[ __ ] mega church you look around and
know that one of these [ __ ]
down there
is [ __ ] kids
one of them is
odds on one of them [ __ ] down there
is [ __ ] kids
and I and I just can't take it man I'm
with you Gabe I can't take it anymore
and I just want to you know I've seen
some people in the chat here who are
[ __ ] idiots uh you know fake Gabe and
others who say things like these three
guys are [ __ ] I'm sorry that I'm a
[ __ ] because I [ __ ] care about human
life I'm sorry that I'm a [ __ ] that I
care about the fact that we shouldn't
have to worry about people going into a
[ __ ] club and shooting people with an
AR-15 I'm sorry that I'm a [ __ ] that
I'm calling this [ __ ] [ __ ] out and
that you amongst other people in the
chat whoever you are in Anonymous
[ __ ] keyboard Warriors you want to
hide behind it in your basement asking
mom for your [ __ ] tater tots
saying oh I'm a big tough guy oh yeah I
got my [ __ ] gun in the background
I'll just [ __ ] you man you're I'm sorry
that I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] for calling
this [ __ ] out for what it is it's gross
it's disgusting it's vile it is not how
we treat other people murdering humans
for what they believe in you gotta be
out of your [ __ ] mind
have you seen pictures of this little
fat [ __ ] this little this little cuck
that went in there that decided to kill
these son of a [ __ ] because he hates
a certain group of people because people
like Matt Walsh and fake Gabriel in the
chat say this stupid that was a real
[ __ ] alpha male right there yeah I I
tell you what I tell you what where I
come from where I come from fake Gabe
where I come from if someone pulls a gun
on you
you will get your [ __ ] ass beat you
better use that [ __ ] you better
if you pull a gun on somebody where I'm
from you better you better [ __ ] use
that son of a [ __ ] and you better be
willing to use that son of a [ __ ]
because you're gonna get your [ __ ]
ass kicked just like that just like the
little the little manga cuck the little
Mass shooter
have decided he's going to kill people
because Tucker Carlson told him so Matt
Walsh told him so
got his ass kicked damn near to an inch
of his life now I I I know I want to
continue on this subject but I got I got
to move on
um I want to talk about
um Trump and some of these cases that
are happening um because there is some
news Kyle Chaney actually just posted
about an hour ago it looks like Trump's
lawyers are getting really [ __ ]
desperate here
um now now that the special counsel has
been assigned they're going to do more
and more desperate [ __ ]
um and Kyle Chaney reports Justin
Trump's lawyer going back to the well
with judge Cannon you remember judge
Cannon is the one that you know give him
some reprieve but not enough to get out
of this situation
um he goes on to say asking her to
unseal the affidavit accompanying the
Mar-A-Lago search warrant so they're
really trying their damnedest to try to
get everything out in the open so they
can cause more chaos that's what I see
this as
um Kyle goes on to say here unclear
unclear this request is even in her
purview so she may not be able to do
this that's why they're probably asking
her because they know the actual person
who would be able to do this would tell
them to [ __ ] off he goes on to say
rather than a magistrate who approved
the warrant and so the judge or the
Magistrate
that approved the search woman warrant
for Mar-A-Lago would be the one who
would issue the unsealing of this
affidavit that went with that search
warrant that that judge or that
magistrate approved for that search for
those documents
um what do you um and here's the actual
document here if you want to go see it
and I'll retweet Kyle here in case you
guys want to go look at that what do you
guys make of this new filing
well I know there was one thing going on
there was a hearing today
um the the and it just shows you how
much Jack Smith I I am leery to put my
eggs in any basket because you never
know where it's going to go look at
Mueller you never know where it's going
to end up he issues a perfectly credible
report explaining how Trump is is [ __ ]
over and owned by Russia and then you
get a guy like Bill Barr that totally
[ __ ] rips that apart apart and and
and puts the flip side report out so
until I get something thing in my hand
I'm not going to jump on the Jack Smith
wagon but I will tell you this that dude
hit the ground [ __ ] run it right when
he's working when is that hearing today
news from that go ahead yeah yeah what
Jack Smith did was you know when they
said hey we're going to bring in a
special prosecutor he didn't wait till
it was signed he got his [ __ ] in order
they sent him every because what Trump
was trying to do today was say oh well
this they've got a special prosecutor
now this doj hearing over the documents
of Mar-A-Lago you know we can't you know
we can't have that because you know
you're talking about a special
prosecutor now well the special
prosecutor sent a letter to the judge
yesterday saying I'm on top of this doj
filing and I 100 concur with it
[ __ ] you I mean so so that Avenue closed
so now they're trying to run back to
that [ __ ] judge that that that does all
kinds of unheard of crazy legal [ __ ] for
Trump
because she's a she's a she has no
[ __ ] loyalty to her the bench this
country our constitution our legal
system she is all in for that fascist
[ __ ] mango Mussolini [ __ ]
well I do want to say about the Jack
Smith reading the full briefing for
anyone who was not aware Merrick Garland
didn't assign the special Counsel on a
whim like this is not something that he
he just was like I gotta do it now
they've been thinking about this for
[ __ ] months if Trump was going to
announce and I'm almost positive that
they had the brief ready for [ __ ] for
whoever the special prosecutor was going
to be at that moment to think that
Merrick Garland is not prepared here is
really [ __ ] stupid it's really dumb
to think that Merrick Garland is not
going to go into a special counsel
appointment without being fully prepared
to do that especially with this um with
this uh hearing that was today and I
guess
Trump has already re uh reverse course
on his partaking remember remember he
said I will not partake as if it's like
a [ __ ] okay this is like a like is he
saying he's gonna partake now well well
he actually this is
well because he's already he's already
they filed something saying that his
rights have been violated so now he's
he's already partaking which is really
stupid let me tell you something if
you're being prosecuted in a federal
[ __ ] court and they're going to
arraign you on your charges on your
indictment they don't give two [ __ ]
they don't give two [ __ ] if you're
gonna partake or not they don't give a
[ __ ] it's not like oh I gotta yeah right
it's not like oh I gotta I got a like a
parking or a speeding ticket you're like
I won't partake and they're like okay
we'll we'll just keep finding you and
then at a certain point if your car
[ __ ] comes up on the on the reader
again we're gonna boot it and if from
there we're gonna [ __ ] tow it like
also if you have unpaid parking tickets
we can hold you in court or like old
like in jail until you pay those fines
so it's the whole idea is like I will
not partake good [ __ ] luck man I
really hope you the best of luck if you
decide to not partake
but obviously if he is partaking by
saying his rights were violated
no rights were violated not this [ __ ]
has been out in the open and the reason
we know so much is because Trump [ __ ]
[ __ ] and moans about it so then of
course the doj's like all right fine
here's a little bit more right we're
adapted here's a little bit more
redacted you know and then they're like
all right fine here's more unredacted
and each time it makes him look like a
[ __ ] idiot and then you've got Canon
who's like oh yeah let me make these
unprecedented moves by a judge myself
that has been appointed by the man that
is in question right now no conflict of
interest clearly where the legal
community and other judges like what the
[ __ ] is she doing right like that is the
consensus across everyone else which is
like uh that's not how this goes and
that is you won you should have recused
yourself and two that that's it's not
how it works you can't just decide this
is how the law applies right now and
this is what your interpretation is
so it's and I think uh Texas Paul shared
an article uh I get I got it I gotta go
in here
um was there something in here Texas
Paul that you wanted to comment on
specifically
you're muted there Texas Paul
you're on mute
you can't hear us
sorry bud I thought it on mute so I
don't sit and breathe in the microphone
my eyes I've been sick so I trying not
to cough and [ __ ] into the microphone go
ahead no it was a hearing they had today
about what to do with the special
Masters report and and they were trying
the maneuver the Trump team was trying
to do 11 circuit appeals case where
they're trying to appeal uh this certain
um um powers that the special master has
yeah Cliff's Notes is they asked for a
special Master Trump's people asked for
a special Master they got a special
Master didn't like what the [ __ ]
the special Master did now they're
fighting the special master and their
maneuver today was to try to say oh
we've got a special prosecutor now this
whole special Master's report you know
we can't have those prior you know
rulings and [ __ ] involved because now
we've got a special prosecutor and and
you're somehow [ __ ] muddying the
waters with the special prosecutor
special prosecutor sent a note before
the hearing saying Reddit done it
understand it I'm behind it this is me
this is me just consider this me
and so now now they they ran back to
[ __ ] Eileen Cannon please do
something for me please you know and she
and she's just [ __ ] bed bug crazy
enough to try to do it too she has
totally [ __ ] destroyed her judicial
career I mean I think though as you go
through that timeline the funniest part
was when Trump was like well you know I
think it would only be fair that the doj
pays 50
of the legal bills even though he's the
one who wanted this [ __ ] yeah it's like
you asked for it we've said you could
have it we even approved the person that
you suggested so stop crying they picked
his yeah they picked his we gave it to
you and then and he by the way is
[ __ ] no no [ __ ] like he does not
give a [ __ ] he's like look we're gonna
play this uh this is not my first rodeo
and also we're gonna make sure that we
follow the [ __ ] to the law right
especially coming from a group that says
Law and Order lawn order oh I'm sorry
that you don't like it when Law and
Order is literally applied to you
the projection and the hypocrisy is it
is Non-Stop
and just to throw a little another thing
out there about Merrick Garland and I'm
again I reserve my judgment on all this
[ __ ] till I see some [ __ ] happen but
Merrick Garland is
I mean he's never missed
he has never missed in his entire career
because that [ __ ] you remember Top Gun
you had like Maverick and Iceman [ __ ]
he's Iceman he is quiet he's reserved
and [ __ ] deadly and I guarantee you
he was working with with Jack Smith well
before Jackson he signed the
documentation
um Jack Smith is up to speed this is not
going to take another year to come about
they're not going to let this run into
the next Congress where the next
Congress can [ __ ] instruct that's it
you had Jim Jordan say he was going to
open an investigation in Congress
on Jack Smith
okay do it [ __ ] do it that's
called obstruction of justice right I
tell you what try to try to [ __ ] with
this funding that's also obstruction of
justice you are some dumb [ __ ]
man you really are yeah you've got Matt
Gates saying that we should defund any
okay any anyone you got Marjorie Taylor
Grant at one point saying we should
defund the FBI right because she was
like oh no no FBI can't look into me
can't look into Trump can't look into
anyone in our involvement with uh Jan
six right you've got Matt Gates recently
on Steve bannon's [ __ ] traitor TV
show that says oh we should defund their
investigation anytime there is any
moment of any sort of Investigation
that's looking to them for doing the
illegal things that they blame on other
people they're like whoa hey hey guys
let's uh abolish the investigation
it can we like kill this you know well
that's because I get that I've got that
clip right here let's listen it's not
what we should be seeing in the United
States of America but I don't want to
sit around hand ringing and bedwetting
over this I think we ought to use the
power of the purse to defund this
explicitly political exercise against
President Trump
so you're saying if if Merrick Garland
doesn't do the proper thing and just
remove Smith uh or if Smith doesn't do
the honorable thing and recuse himself
because of his bias and his wife's
obviously hatred Trump you're saying
that the the house ought to throw down
hard and just defund the entire thing
correct
of course because there is no Rhyme or
Reason to this it feels it feels like to
me that this is two people who know
they're gonna be uh you know there
there's gonna be rocks uncovered in this
investigation that yeah implicate them
yeah and the [ __ ] that they're
trying to throw out there is that the
Jack Smith's wife made political
donations to the Biden campaign
you know Clarence Thomas Jenny [ __ ]
Thomas anybody yeah that's like that's
like Carrie Lake screaming oh Hobbs has
to recuse herself because she can't run
her own election
Brian Kemp [ __ ]
you know I'm sorry I don't live by a
different set of rules than you do you
make a [ __ ] rule we live by it
[ __ ]
that's the way it works
I want to show you something else that's
happening in Trump World
um because that was our title today's
Trump's the greatest loser like he's
going to do a lot of losing today
um I believe
because the Oath Keepers trial also is
in deliberation now for the jury which I
think he's going to lose big in that one
too
um I said Greg Kelly is complaining here
of course because he's such a [ __ ]
snowflake you know this great Kelly is
this [ __ ] guy on Newsmax this guy is
such a little [ __ ] okay I said oh Greg
here is gonna go down with the Cheeto
dust Titanic now Mike Pompeo
who called
um the national chair of the teachers
union I believe
um called her the greatest threat into
the world or some [ __ ] as if education
is a threat I guess it's a threat I mean
the knowledge right and actual education
that would better our society because
you know that's just like the natural
progression of human evolution uh it's
it's a threat right of course
knowledge is a huge threat well the
antithesis of the Republican Party well
he says here about Mike Pompeo because
Mike Pompeo went to some um I don't know
what the hell this is some kind of
Coalition or something where he's making
jokes
and Greg Kelly says watch with capital
letters Mike Pompeo totally bomb capital
letters these guys really [ __ ] [ __ ]
to Trump with this stuff with his snide
jokes about Trump quote secretary Mike
like I don't know if there's like a
class that these people take on how to
how to tweet like Trump is there a class
that they give out is it like a master
class on how to tweet like Trump this
[ __ ] ridiculous I mean I I took a
master class yeah well I and now and now
they they actually pay me to teach
that's right okay oh so is that is that
your side gig is that yeah is that uh
Andrew Tate's Hustler University oh my
God that's [ __ ] hilarious so so he
says go ahead
you know why these guys are so [ __ ]
Terror just terrified of the whole
education situation because we have
started to actually teach real history
you know all throughout history you had
like Daughters of the Confederacy and
all of these groups that [ __ ] pump
propaganda in our history you want to
talk about taking your heritage away
these [ __ ] took your heritage
away right because they just put
propaganda propaganda [ __ ] into your
history class everybody in Gen X your
[ __ ] history was classes in high
school were useless completely useless
I'll tell you something like sacrosanct
here in the state of Texas is the Alamo
well I hate to tell you this the good
guys at the Alamo were the ones on the
outside all right they were there to
fight slavery the ones inside were
holding [ __ ] slave sales and that's
why Santa Ana came up and destroyed the
[ __ ] Alamo because he told him no
slaves
and they don't want that history Davy
Crockett King of the Wild Frontier okay
so so the other thing that they do with
education they say leave [ __ ] out like
um you know the Tulsa Massacre white
people just found out about this a few
years ago and I was talking to another
friend of mine he's a teacher and he's
like we were talking about it and he's
like why didn't we know about this I'm
like because we're white he's like
really you think that's I said yeah
that's absolutely that's absolutely why
we had no clue about this thing why do
you think [ __ ] racists are so mad at
[ __ ] black panther and black panther
wakanda right like you've got people
like [ __ ] uh Tim Poole saying oh yeah
it's racist against Mexicans oh boy oh
do I oh [ __ ] man I got so pissed when I
saw that [ __ ] I was like are you talking
they're literally playing Mesoamerican
ball underwater you [ __ ] kidding me
but for people like that they get so
pissed
because God forbid there's a true
and fair representation of people who
are not white right oh and I'm sorry the
white guy is the evil person in the
story tends to be reflective of History
I love how they call I love the part
where he's chained in the back and he's
like and she says um
she says uh that's my favorite colonizer
and chains yeah oh yeah that's right
that's a great line so this this clip of
Mike Pompeo here now now this is the
reason why I want to show this is
because this is a great wedge driver
we're always talking about National
narratives here on the show we're always
talking about how to push nerds I want
to remind everyone tomorrow for the
Wednesday show we have Dr Rachel
bittickoffer the the absolute [ __ ]
Master at messaging by the way she's
going to join us tomorrow for our
special Thanksgiving Wednesday show I
love her I love her if he says CRT in
this video if he says CRT in this video
you need to know what they mean by CRT
is real so they don't want real history
taught so here's here's what he's saying
in this video this is like a like a
little comedy bit that was written for
him he poorly executes it right yeah
yeah but Greg Kelly is [ __ ] pissed
off that he's knocking on Trump trump is
done Trump is [ __ ] done people the
only only reason why you still have
these [ __ ] people still sycophanting
to to him is because they're going to be
wrapped up in these investigations let
me tell you something there's going to
be thousands
thousands thousands of people who go to
prison for Trump and because of trump
thousands of people
and Mike Pompeo does not want to be one
of those people
the reason why Matt gets Steve Bannon
Mike Flynn Marjorie Taylor green are
still sick of fanting to that son of a
[ __ ] is because they're likely to be
some of the ones but listen to what Mike
Pompeo says here this is great fodder
this is great wedge driving that we can
do uh it's good to see you it's great to
be a warm-up act tonight foreign
who knows the next time we're together
we could be on a stage multiple podiums
who knows who else might be with us yeah
who knows
and uh and and who knows who will
between us and who knows what nicknames
we might have it's uh
it is uh
it is great fun to be with so many uh
friends there so there it is he's making
fun of trump obviously there and Greg
Kelly I mean absolutely [ __ ] butt
hurt about it now the reason why I bring
this up the reason why I want to show
people this and I know it doesn't seem
relevant because everyone's hating on
Mike Pompeo this is exactly why we need
to drive this wedge because Mike Pompeo
is a [ __ ] box 100 [ __ ] box so let's put
a [ __ ] box up against a [ __ ] box and let
them fight it out here that's the wedge
you need to drive also like these the
the digs that he made were too horrible
right yeah are they jokes really yeah no
I'm not saying that I'm not saying that
they're [ __ ] High Caliber jokes here
but they're two jokes that were made
which is like oh maybe you'll see me on
stage with Trump and others running
right because is gonna run right
suggestions and he's like oh and maybe
when we're on stage we'll get nicknames
that were given by Trump because that's
what he does literally those are the two
jokes that was it the summary of two
things
Greg Kelly got so in the [ __ ] feels
for this he was so upset that he made
two and set up and you know for a group
that calls other people snowflakes holy
[ __ ] man right those were not even those
were not anyway insulting of his weight
his intelligence uh his his uh lack of
or or desperation for sexual encounters
that he has to pay from none of those
jokes were made none of them this was
literally a debate joke and a nickname
joke you know Texas Paul
um he's Greg Kelly says loyalty Mike in
other words Mike Pompeo has to have
loyalty to Trump here's what I believe I
believe Donald Trump would chew up Mike
Pompeo on stage and spit him out on the
floor like Mike Pompeo is such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's such a [ __ ] when he went and
he made the deal with the with the
[ __ ] Taliban and [ __ ] and he
genuflected them and all this nonsense
somehow Mike Pompeo is this tough guy
[ __ ] right I believe that Donald
Trump and this is this is going to be
the best part about this [ __ ] 2024
campaign is that Donald Trump is not
running against Joe Biden Donald Trump
is going to be running against Mike
Pence Pompeo DeSantis uh Larry Hogan
possible Glenn yunkin he Doug Ducey he's
going to be running against these
[ __ ] [ __ ] boxes and they're gonna
have to fight it out and I'm excited I'm
excited Texas Paul about watching Donald
Trump and Mike Pompeo [ __ ] fight on
stage it's going to be fantastic I think
it's gonna be fantastic oh yeah man
because the Republicans know they're
fighting for their lives this time I
mean this is it if this [ __ ] gets back
in this is it you know they I mean
you're talking about fascism you're
talking about these [ __ ] will hang
man and they are fighting for their
lives it's just going to be a very very
interesting primary because it can't be
like you know you
you know Donald Trump just flat out
insulting Heidi Cruz's looks right in
front of Ted Cruz and you can tell that
dude is not Texas born and bred you know
that [ __ ] was brought in from
out of country because if you insulted
my wife on stage I would be beating you
with the [ __ ] podium
you know you would be eating Podium you
know right Ted Cruz is like a little
[ __ ] that sits there and and just looks
at him and does nothing and then now
he's out there like sucking his balls I
mean these people are yeah
Ted Cruz is a [ __ ] let's just call what
it is right the guy is willing
to it he's willing to accept insults
against his own wife and doesn't say
[ __ ] just accepts it and he's like ah I
mean that's how it is now like hey
that's pretty disrespectful that's
pretty misogynistic that's pretty uh you
know that is that is not what a
political candidate can do but as soon
and this goes to your point way earlier
Texas Paul
for too long people have said yeah
that's okay not my business not gonna
call that [ __ ] out right and this is
another example where you had Trump inch
by inch [ __ ] step over the line and
do things that were small at first
things that should have been called out
immediately and things that were
personal to many people like Ted Cruz
like hey your wife's ugly and your dad
was connected with the JFK [ __ ]
assassination those are things that you
might want to say uh defamation and also
that's just unprofessional that's not
political that's not how we hold
ourselves as the Republican party but
they didn't do anything so then everyone
began to accept that as truth and accept
that as a totally acceptable behavior in
running for president or being a
politician what the temperature
and think about how short Donald Trump's
political career would have been if
little [ __ ] Marco had turned around
and said what did you say [ __ ]
right and stepped up to Donald Trump
because Daniel Donald Trump is a [ __ ]
coward man he is a coward he is a fat
old man coward and I guarantee you if
somebody has shown an ounce of balls and
stepped up to him when he was running
his mouth on stage that would have been
the end of Trump's career that would
have been it he's a [ __ ] I mean he is a
[ __ ] but none of them yeah but none of
them had the balls to stand up so now
they've got to own that [ __ ] [ __ ]
stained diaper-filled [ __ ] well
here's here's Ted Cruz talking about the
special counsel seems like uh Ted Cruz
is a little worried about the special
counsel might undercover some rocks that
has Ted Cruz's crimes the other thing is
uh Santa Cruz it seems to me the remit
here is far-reaching that you're talking
about a major fishing expedition in the
next couple years As Trump may or may
not run or get through the primaries I'm
not here to predict that outcome but I
am here to criticize what's the remit
it's not just Mar-A-Lago it's not just
January 6. this thing could roam far and
wide into who knows there yeah
look Larry I've talked about this at
Great length on the podcast that I do
three times a week verdict with Ted Cruz
where we've gone in and explained what's
going on inside at doj and and you
really go back a couple of months ago
when doj began leaking that they intend
to indict Hunter Biden and and set aside
for a second the doj leaking that's not
how a department of justice is supposed
to operate that's pure politics okay so
first off he's gonna throw the lamp dump
and he's gonna throw his podcast in this
[ __ ] guy is just a Shameless piece of
garbage like this is the same guy that
you would imagine if his state would
lose their power and the citizens would
lose power and he'd be like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I'm not freezing I'm going to
Cancun is this that same guy is that
this is the same guy that then also
blamed it on both of his daughters and
said I was just being a good father and
it's like you didn't need both parents
to fly to Cancun for a little Resort
getaway all right well I could go on
with Ted Cruz here but here's the point
that I want to make about day cruise and
this clip with Larry Kudlow what what
what the Republicans are really scared
of is this special counsel they can keep
under
overturning rocks and overturning rocks
and overturning racks and overturning
rocks and do new indictments that have
nothing to do with Mar-A-Lago that
nothing to do with January 6th if they
find crime they can prosecute that [ __ ]
that's what these [ __ ] are terrified
of because that's one thing that Donald
Trump did to these [ __ ] is turn
them all into crooked ass criminals
because they believed he would somehow
pardon him because he would say that
[ __ ] meetings oh just commit crime I'll
pardon you they feel good and not only
that but you also have to remember the
fact that we literally had nine
Insurrection hearings with a a committee
putting in in front of millions of
viewers and being rebroadcasted by Midas
Touch Network and other people hitting
those clips again and again and again
those sound bites writing about it
sharing about it educating
it's why the Republican party doesn't
like it educating the public on what
really went down right it wasn't just a
[ __ ] tourist visit it wasn't just a
normal [ __ ] run-of-the-mill day it
was a [ __ ] Insurrection where people
died and people were attempting to kill
other people it's not not normal thing
that we should accept as uh how our
country runs right and if we did then
our country would be in a much worse
place right and thankfully democracy
during the midterms [ __ ] stood up and
said [ __ ] no
but the reason
that this is so important and that
they're so scared is because it's
different than the mother report which
the Mueller report was done in some
sense of a public eye but you never
really heard anything and then when
things were released they were redacted
and Bill Barr came in and then we found
out later after the fact that bill Barr
actually did obstruct in ways but the
reason that they're so [ __ ] pissed
off and scared is because this was all
broadcasted to the public first so now
everyone has [ __ ] context they all
know what's going on they've seen video
they've heard audio they've been given
testimony from literally all Republicans
people within the proud boys group
people that were there on January 6
people that were part and hearing these
legal Theory arguments like Rusty Bowers
all of these people
were were put on full display so of the
American people know exactly what's
going on and there's a backlog of of
information that they can hear about and
learn about and now they're so scared is
because people know about it people
people have knowledge of what it is so
now they're more Curious and so when the
[ __ ] follows through Jack Smith isn't
working from he's not working from
ground zero here he's working from he's
like already halfway up the [ __ ]
Summit he's got everything booked
categorized cataloged cross-referenced
testimonies here knows who to follow up
with that's why they're so scared is
because they're thinking it's going to
be a year two years of Investigation but
all this [ __ ] is already [ __ ] right
in front of them it's already in boxes
ready to go it's already digitized Liz
Cheney's [ __ ] hand delivering that
[ __ ] with a little Hershey's kiss on top
so Texas ball you know I wish give us
your two minutes because while you're
doing that I'm gonna prepare my Tuesday
thank Thanksgiving dinner here why
you're doing that
okay look let me be honest with you I
want my kinstar you know you've got
people crying oh Jack Smith is partisan
because his wife made a donation [ __ ]
that noise I want my Ken star
Ken Starr couldn't find [ __ ] all on what
he was assigned to investigate nothing
zip did you hear of one charge that came
out of of any of the real estate deals
that he was supposed to be investigating
not one zero not a zip he and Brett
Kavanaugh was his assistant who's now
sitting on the [ __ ] Supreme Court
sat there with their thumbs up their ass
and had nothing so what did they do
Monica Lewinsky that's what they did
something totally out of their purview
something they were totally why because
they were partisan they were [ __ ]
partisan that's what I want in my
special prosecutors we're Democrats we
own the government right now give me a
[ __ ] partisan prosecutor give me
somebody give me a Jack Smith that will
[ __ ] look at this and if he doesn't
find anything find something you know
that's where I'm at [ __ ] this special
set of rules for everybody else you know
[ __ ] this specialist [ __ ] that I want a
partisan [ __ ] in there I mean
look I think I think he will I think the
investigation will obviously I mean like
there's a clear crime we all saw we all
heard it we all watched it happen in
real time and then got a uh a refresher
right so I think they will certainly
find something but if they find other
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I don't [ __ ] care
[ __ ] pull up all the Rocks all the
dirty laundry oh oh there was a text
message unrelated about somebody [ __ ]
cheating on somebody
created that some kind of entity that
committed tax fraud boom indictment yeah
oh nothing to do with January 6th what
do you got there Paul he's got actual
tacos again no he's got actual tacos
Tony I got paper plate look at that wow
look at that wow oh you made it you
asked him my wife was listening dude I
told you that I couldn't have another
[ __ ] tacos she ran in here and
slammed this thing down on my desk
you will not eat that [ __ ] again right
this is this is delicious oh my it's
actually pretty good isn't it
early early Thanksgiving early
Thanksgiving dinner yeah well I feel
sorry that's what I love about you Tony
you got balls man
I don't have balls because according to
the chat I'm a [ __ ] because I care
about human life so [ __ ] it
oh there's been some [ __ ] up
individuals in chat today that really
are just laughable but what can you do
what do you do
the squeegee says uh Gabe you should
pardon my turkey
um it it is a beef stick it is not a
turkey
by the way I just want to point that out
and I'm sure and and it is real easy
cheese it's all it says even on there
made with real cheese so it must be
whenever I see that's where cheese comes
from as if I think of the Goofy movie is
that the Goofy movie where he like
sprays easy cheese yeah yeah
oh okay everybody thanks for joining us
today Texas ball thanks for coming by as
every single Tuesday
um I'm gonna I'm gonna go finish my uh
my lunch here
um it's delicious I'm with Texas Paul
this uh easy cheese uh Slim Jims and a
good idea look Gabe me Amigo I already
told Tony I wish his family you have a
wonderful holiday my friend it is always
fun to be here guys thank you everybody
in the chat I hope you have a wonderful
Thanksgiving and kick off to your
holidays I already got my Christmas mug
out I am ready to go you see it there it
is yeah I love that mug that's my
favorite Christmas mug right there
if you're out there traveling for the
holidays make sure to be safe
um there is a lot of sickness going
around that's what I've been
um dealing with I I I I tell you I was
scared this morning that I was gonna
lose my voice because yesterday I
coughed and coughed and coughed but I
made it through I had my voice tomorrow
we'll be back again we we're just doing
Monday Tuesday Wednesday this week we
won't we will be off Thursday and Friday
we won't have bonehead show we will have
a poll though so don't forget to to
subscribe right here at YouTube you'll
be able to vote on the community tab at
Tony Michaels podcast go follow us on
Twitter why Twitter still exists at Tony
Michaels pod you'll be able to vote
there as well and also download every
single episode this week there'll only
be three Monday Tuesday Wednesday and
tomorrow's episode we got Dr Rachel
bidikoffer here for the special
Wednesday Thanksgiving uh episode I
can't wait to hear what her updates on
the midterms and what messaging is going
forward I always look forward to her
take on messaging
um she she is someone we definitely need
to listen to in this country as
pro-democracy people Everyone same time
same place tomorrow noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific YouTube Twitter and
twitch simulcasting from the minus touch
Facebook page until then Surf's Up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
foreign